and we're rolling how are you Tony
awesome thank you my pleasure thanks for
having yeah thanks for coming here man
yeah hey thanks for watching it's an
honor it's interesting to see you even
just [ __ ] around with your skateboard
just the way you maneuver it so you're
so adept it's really weird like the way
you move your feet and just pick it up
and oh I mean it really is just at this
point kind of extension to our body it
seems like and it's I guess it's weird I
don't think about how comfortable I am
and a lot of times we'll be in a city or
something or just like now I didn't know
where to park right so I just parked
somewhere kind of close and just I go
skate and I feel way better about doing
that than like parking and then walking
somewhere and just you know I know I can
get around people and sort of be
indiscreet and and stealthy with
indiscreet well I'm just saying like a
port is in this piece sure sure yeah
then I guess a lot of do a kick flips
out from car window really yeah that's
funny
yeah that's my curse that I that I
that's my burden I carry I've seen these
new skateboards that are they look like
convertibles whereas these guys flip the
board the wheels flip up and go yeah
that's that's sort of a phenomenon sort
of a social media thing going on so you
can see it in slow-mo is that what it is
know where the board is actually a
contraption right yeah I don't I don't
really understand what that is there's
there's a select few people doing that
yeah and I've seen a couple where they
actually have figured out how to make
their board grind and then do a flip
around a rail as they jump back on it oh
boy yeah that's it's very specialized
though I can't say that's a movement
it's just a few key people don't have
any bones do you have to break but I sis
dude sliding down rails I'm like how
many times do you [ __ ] that up yeah
before arm I while skating went through
a different different waves of
disciplines basically and in the early
90s it was all Street right and so what
I did was was vert skating that was kind
of dying out so I I was skating Street a
lot too and I realized I was not fit to
be a street skater
third time I rolled my ankle like both
ankles twice then the third time the
other one I was like I don't want to
handrails anymore this is not working
for me
this impact is I'm not gonna be able to
skate anymore if I keep doing this I see
these kids like whenever you go like
near like a large office building that
has a lot of outdoor space and you see
them using the rails and stuff like how
many breaks can you have before like I
there I think that it's a little
deceiving because people do you know how
to fall relatively safely from from
stuff like that but they get addicted
right there doing that probably every -
yeah for sure and it there's there's all
kinds of different styles so there's
textiles where it's more people are
skating ledges and benches and you know
the flipping their board grinding
flipping out stuff like that where it's
low-impact but super technical and then
there's just the stuntmen who are doing
the big rail it's the big gaps you know
jumping fences and how did this happen
like what was like how did it go from
just riding escape like when I was a kid
you and I are the same age but when I
was I guess I was probably like 11 or 12
on a skateboard I was just riding it on
the street with all my friends we just
ride a skateboard on the street like
what happened like how did it get to be
like grinding across benches railings
like I think there's a well there's a
pretty deep history there of how a God
there but skating was yeah just more
like a transportation toy and then it
was really the the dog town crew that
took it to a new level where it was like
oh you can use this to do aerials and
skate swimming pools and they were just
trying to emulate their surfing and so
then skate parks started cropping up
skating got popular in the late 70s
early 80s and then it was all swimming
pools and then maybe like four years
later the skateboarding kind of started
falling in popularity the the skate
parks couldn't get their insurance
anymore because the liability was crazy
and so then the streets became the skate
park because there was nowhere else to
go and there was this there were a few
key skaters that that figured out how to
use like the urban landscape as a skate
park and then that was it like
it was all bets are off skating kind of
took off in the underground as the
street culture a street sport and then
people started doing handrails ledges
benches stairs because they just didn't
have parks how much of an impact of the
Internet have on it cuz it seems like
once kids could see all these YouTube
videos of people doing all this crazy
[ __ ] it must have really accelerated it
IIIi think what it did I mean especially
in the last 10 years it even the playing
field
you didn't have to live in Southern
California you didn't have to live in
New York or be near where the industry
is you just be in your little town as
long as you're putting out content and
it's progressive you're gonna get
noticed and I think that's awesome yeah
that is awesome yeah yeah that's one of
the cool things about it like you said
evened out the playing field yeah and
and you know people are making careers
as skaters now in the most unlikely
places well you are the Lance Armstrong
of skating and this is what I mean I
don't mean that you got caught doing
drugs what I mean is that yeah you're
the got like when people talk about
professional skaters Tony Hawk like I
don't know a single [ __ ] bike rider
other than Lance Armstrong I mean Greg
there was another guy Greg LeMond yeah
see but I can't remember him real quick
but for you it's that's got to be
strange to like you were the first and
you're for sure the most prominent like
how did you pull that off
uh well mostly longevity by surviving
the first wave of skating in the 80s I
was actually kind of the second wave of
skating in the 80s where I had a pretty
good career I was doing really well in
competition especially in the in the mid
to late 80s and then as skating kind of
went underground I never quit and
started my own skate company in 1992 and
then when the X Games came into play I
was still kind of on top of my game I
did really well there and I think a lot
of people carried over my name from that
that first round where they were skaters
in the 80s and now maybe their kids
skate and they're like I remember that
guy you know and their kids are watching
me on the X Games and then when our
video game came out in 1999 that's when
everything changed for sure well you
were famous for skating when you were
like 17 or something right I turned pro
when I was 14
and then but I mean that when I say that
it seems it might seem magical but at
the time skating was this little tiny
scene so when I first when I literally
went pro I filled was filling out an
entry form to a competition and I had
already reached the top of the amateur
ranks and there was a little box that
said Pro and a little box said am so I
clicked I checked the pro box now was it
I was proud
no one was offering me a contract no one
had champagne you don't I mean and and
like my coach was I'll never forget
stacy peralta was looking over my
shoulder and I checked it and he's like
okay that's it that was it yeah Wow but
you had a coach we had it we had a team
manager he he's the one who put me on
what is now considered the Bones Brigade
but the company was powell-peralta
and that was sort of the elite crew of
skaters in the in the early 80s and I
was the super young newbie on the team
like super skinny dorky kid and a lot of
the guys that were established were like
this guy really what do you that's me at
age 17 time flies does it freak you out
look at that
um I think it's I mean I see that photo
making the round so it's cool I'm
actually so by the time I turned 17 I
was kind of doing well in competition
and making money so I'm literally
sitting outside of my house that I
bought while I was a senior in high
school in that photo which was a
challenge trying to stay focused on
schoolwork when you have the party house
that's crazy you own a [ __ ] house
yeah Wow a duplex but yeah was my own
place but you know like when you're a
senior oh this is someone's parents are
out of town parties at his house like my
parents were never home so everyone's
going to my house but what did your
parents think about you buying a house
is my dad's idea really yeah because he
saw me really not understanding finances
or
how lucky I was and I was just throwing
money away you know on cars and trips
and sharper image just the most
ridiculous things and then he's like I
really think you should invest your
money you get a massage chair sharper
image massage chair no but I bought
between ok this is a long story but my
sister and I went in on a tanning bed
together it was like I used it once she
used it because she it was helpful to
her skin am I gonna say why but you know
she had a legitimate reason for it but I
was like yeah tanning bed like we're
gonna go tan but you know you got to
have it where did you live at the time
in North County San Diego Carlsbad you
don't need a tanning bed exactly yeah
and that was it was the first time I
went I was like why am i laying in that
just go to the exhaust sorry hundred
fifty days a year yeah that's hilarious
but I mean it's it almost you know when
you're that age and you're you're doing
well you think that some other some like
a status symbol did you sleep in that
house by yourself when you were 17 no I
had three roommates oh god that's so
crazy match one was a little bit older
he was a good friend of mine Pro Skater
and he was the only guy that actually
had a job and he was tortured for like
two years cuz we were super late all the
time making noise and you'd have to get
up at you know 7 a.m. go to work he was
doing he was doing line stripping like
Backlund you'd have to color separate
for magazines and stuff like that
it was bummer for him such a bummer yeah
and still Charlie he's still trying to
make it as a pro skater but clearly he
had to get a job and must be an
exhausted - yeah he would leave these
kind of nasty notes for us in the
morning so will you in high school look
so you're a senior year in high school
you had your own place did you do any
schoolwork at all I did yeah um he must
have been like [ __ ] this I can already
buy a house I I don't know I I think it
was more because my parents valued
education my mom was an educator she was
actually like taught in a college Wow
so I felt that
gonna be a disappointment if I didn't at
least graduate high school and I was
always pretty advanced like I was in the
gifted program and you know I was a
great ahead and a lot of the subjects so
by the time I was a senior I only needed
four classes to graduate so I went to
school until lunchtime everyday and then
I was out Wow
and then I got my diploma and my dad not
strongly suggested I go look at colleges
and so just to humor him I went looking
at like a you know a city college in our
area and looked around the campus like
oh that's cool I guess sure and I just
knew that he was my opportunity to
really chase this and to embrace all
these opportunities I was getting I mean
I was I was literally out of high school
onto a Hollywood movie set gleaming the
cube
oh that's right so I I was out just
graduated high school and then moved to
North Hollywood for two months did you
think it was like what 80 say it was it
was shot in 88 I think 87 Wow
god I'm remembering that now Wow
what what a crazy way to go from being a
young kid to like right into your
manhood it's it's deceiving though I
mean we especially when you have that
much success at a young age you think
you think it's never gonna end right you
think you're invincible and I definitely
sometimes treated as such where I was
just like well you know just throwing
money away and and like I said my dad
was encouraging me to save it and then
it all came crashing down in about like
1991 92 where my my paycheck was all
based on royalties of skate products and
it started getting cut in half every
month whoa just from lack of interest
lack of sales why did it drop it was a
just a liability thing it was that and
just skating was considered a fad and
was just like and and also my style of
skating I was I skated the ramps right
so I'm a vert skater vert skating was
just instantly not cool because Street
skating had taken over so I was
considered this dinosaur and it was just
like you're out skating is not
cool and you're not cool in skating Wow
so it was it was rough that was like I
would say sort of 92 to 95 ish were were
very lean so you were trying to figure
out like hey what am i doing I got
really good at this were you thinking I
gotta find something else to do yes and
no I knew I wouldn't quit skating
because I just loved it like I never did
it from the money you know I started
there were no no one could be rich or
famous from skating so that was never
the objective it was just because I
loved what it brought to me I love the
self-confidence it brought to me I love
the creativity I love the the misfit
crew the the community of it and so when
things started to go south financially I
know when quit I just had to figure out
how to make ends meet and I actually had
a video editing system and I learned how
to do that very early like right when
nonlinear video started happening I had
a system so I started doing freelance
work for companies doing video editing
super random some skate companies and
then I did exhibitions like we were
doing exhibitions in amusement park
parking lots we weren't even in the
amusement park we're like in the parking
lot as people walk in as entertainment
you know and doing that for like 100
bucks a day but it but it allowed me to
skate and allowed me to pay the rent and
it was like that was good enough for me
but were you thinking that this is gonna
stop totally well it was definitely felt
like I was heading that way but I like I
said I was trying to I was just trying
to do whatever I could so I was trying
to learn different skills and you know
maybe skating wasn't gonna pay the bills
but I couldn't let it go for my life wow
that's a great story it was there and
you brought it back yeah I guess I mean
a lot of ways right it was um it started
slow they come back really when the X
Games came into playing where suddenly
we were we were on TV and kids could see
how much skating had evolved well the
whole public could see how much skating
and evolved from the time
they last saw it in the late 80s and
then they were seeing and it was like
well these guys are this is for real you
know this is it for lack of a better
word this is a sport these guys are
doing acrobatic things and and it takes
discipline and it takes it takes
determination and and kids recognize
that and I think they you know that's
really when skating started to spark
again and there's like 95 ish probably
more closer in 96 97 the first axioms
was a little strange a little scattered
because it was like skateboarding and
bungee jumping and rock climbing and sky
surfing there they were just throwing
everything and then it really rubbed us
the wrong way because suddenly we were
labeled as extreme and it was like what
do you do i skateboard oh you're into
extreme sports no I'd skateboard I don't
know yeah that's a weird category right
that extremes it was just anything yeah
and that was I mean really it was coined
by ESPN so that's why they changed it to
X Games so the first one was extreme
games 95 they changed the X Games in 96
I think they really found their their
niche a few years later when they really
sort of started to weed out all the
random stuff and it was more about
skateboarding BMX motocross like those
became really the highlights and the
reason people are tuning in and then
that's when things really exploded what
were like the early skateboarding events
and X Games like what did you it was it
was street and vert and so vert came
back yeah yeah a lot of it I think it
was really because yes being recognized
that the vert is a spectator sport yeah
I was gonna say for us on the outside we
would watch it to see someone fall
spectacularly sure guys would go you
would hit those ramps and you would
watch people just [ __ ] up and you're
like oh my God look how far he's falling
right yeah for sure and then once they
got in you know once they evolved that
into what they call the big air ramps
the mega ramps then it was just like the
the aerials and the risk factor was
tenfold yeah the the risk factor I mean
I I've seen some wipeouts that are
I they're baffling I think when when
things started to really explode with
that with the big air thing and then
Jake Brown had his big accident the one
that kind of everyone saw went viral you
probably seen him where he's just
falling from like yeah that's when they
started to I don't want to say tone it
down but but really they started to
figure out how to do it in a way that is
still progressive but not just throwing
caution to the wind and not just trying
to break all the heights and spin
records it was just bad you know they
really refined it he I mean surprisingly
he I think he broke his hand
maybe his his heel and had like internal
bruising but that's it was I mean it was
really unbelievably lucky yeah I watched
that and I was like this guy there's no
way this guy's gonna live and there's
yeah and then and then you know they
didn't have the proper protocol in place
they just let him walk off from ramp it
was nuts yeah it was but but it was
definitely a shock to the system and
like I said they started to refine that
event where it's just like alright you
guys you know listen we're comfortable
at this certain height let's just stick
with that yeah even all those skaters
set it themselves they're like well we
can really work on new tricks at this
height instead of trying to go to the
moon go to the moon right yeah it just
it was is there an issue with CTE with
skaters um well it's definitely a
concern yeah I haven't I can't say that
I know many examples of it but I I'm not
following people past their careers
necessarily you know except for close
friends you know jason Ellis of course
yeah Ellis I think he told me he's been
knocked out like seven or eight times
like out cold
yeah and I've definitely at least that
for me yeah well I I mean I've had
probably by all accounts over the years
at least like thirty you know either
semi concussions or heavy can I'd say
like three or four heavy concussions but
got cold yep how cold just three or four
times look up in the ambulance yeah
and I don't take that lightly like I
don't and especially with all the
information that we have now and with
all the research I went and proactively
tried to figure out if I'm susceptible
because did you get the gene check I did
yeah what is it apoe4 is that what it is
yes I believe so I do not have the gene
that makes me susceptible and I was he
more concerned I mean because my my mom
she passed away recently but she had
Alzheimer's dementia and that makes you
more susceptible to Alzheimer's dementia
not just CTE right I mean I'm I'm acting
like a medical expert I just you know I
I researched it enough to know that ok
I'm not more at risk for that but I
don't you know I'm not I'm not putting
myself out there to be to have
concussions anymore like that what I
mean I'm not doing those kind of moves
that that I was getting knocked out on
have you done anything proactively to
try to I take supplements stuff like
that yeah mm-hmm
do you ever heard of a neuro force no no
neuro one right Nora one there's bill
Romanowski football player created it
it's specifically because he was dealing
with a lot of issues memory issues and
the like okay because of head trauma and
it's like the first nootropic I ever
tried it's really good it's just like it
it's a bunch of nootropics that combined
into delicious but you do feel like your
mental capacity yeah there's a bunch of
stuff that I take that cranks me up
alpha brain which is one that my company
makes on it makes there's another one
neuro gum I really like it's just a gum
I'm willing to try yeah I mean I would
imagine any sort of supplement that
would aid the the function of your brain
sure yeah or anything no I only had a
couple of concussions that affected me
for a longer period of time like for a
week where I couldn't focus or I had
other you know physical issues and I
don't feel any of those effects like
that know you're down in San Diego
there's there's an area outside of San
Diego that cat Zingano went to she's a
UFC fighter
and she fought amanda Nunez who's the
panel a champion now currently and she
got a really bad concussion in that
fight it was it was really [ __ ] her
up to the point where her hormones were
out of whack her cortisol levels were so
[ __ ] up she couldn't she couldn't keep
weight off her whole body was just a
mess she was having a hard time with her
coordination and she went to the center
that they do some sort of magnetic
therapy for people with brain injuries
and it Reese team you lates growth in
those areas of the brain that have been
damaged and brought her back to normal
weight how for a hollowing that take it
took a few months and she was going on a
regular basis and it's a was quite a
trek for her I think it was more than an
hour drive back and forth and she was
doing it I think every day and I believe
the center was developed because you
know San Diego has so much military down
there I believe that's why I lived there
my dad was in the Navy ah and I love San
Diego oh me too
and the mayor actually just asked to go
into stage three they made a request in
San Diego to go into stage three of the
recovery from coronavirus like
everything's great down here let's I
know the rest of the city or the rest of
the state is having issues in some spots
particularly Los Angeles but he feels
ready to rock and roll and push I keep
getting different different views
different news different different
guidelines yeah I don't I you know I'm
just kind of like I'm go out we're in a
mask mm-hmm doing that you know trying
to follow the guidelines as possible as
much as possible while still leading a
relatively normal life yeah it's a weird
time right it's yeah and and the strange
part to me is the the the great divide
in terms of for instance my daughter
loves to get bagels in the morning
before school so I still try to do that
with her sometimes so she can feel like
we're doing a normal school day even
before she goes online and the bagel
shop says like facemask required and
people just walk in without him and give
you dirty looks for wearing the mask and
it's just like I'm just following the
rules of the place I'm just like this
some war of politics here I'm just
following what they're asking me to do
that's so weird
yeah it's it's really it's like they're
making a stand by not I'm like okay well
you know it's the same theory as no
shirt no shoes no shirt no service like
except your stinky feet doesn't get
someone sick you know I mean it's it's a
little different it's a [ __ ] weird
time and it's a weird time politically
it seems like the coronaviruses is a
line in the sand politically absolutely
yeah yeah it's it's a strange time and
like I said I'm just you know doing my
best to follow the guidelines the
experts and and still try to maintain a
semblance of normalcy for my family um
so that you know we feel like we there's
light at the end of the tunnel yeah we
all feel that way yeah it's um just
California in particular is very
restrictive state and when it comes to
the recovery mm-hmm and maybe that's a
good thing maybe that's a bad thing we
really won't know for months you know
yeah yeah exactly
shuttles I'm still like they're certain
appearances and events and things that
have been so-called postponed some are
still are very optimistic where they
think okay we're gonna do it in July
like you think so I don't know or August
sorry we're gonna push it back and it's
just um I just don't know what to
believe and you know I got a I got a
schedule for doing some promotional
stuff for our video game coming out in
September and it's like okay August
going to Europe like are you sure I
don't know are we gonna be let in am I
gonna have to wait in quarantine for two
weeks when I land like I don't know yeah
I have a bunch of dates I've got one in
July in Vegas and then I've got a bunch
in New Orleans I got one in New Orleans
one in Nashville with with Chappelle and
we're just like hopefully it happens
yeah but it's like September 4th and 5th
like really I mean who I mean maybe it's
I never thought this was gonna happen
you never thought we'd be sitting around
in May going there's no way we're gonna
be open in August right
was just gonna be we closed down for a
month you know we take this financial
hit but uh you know the virus settles
down everybody can get back to where we
get testing or whatever whatever takes
place some sort of therapeutic you know
relief something where that comes along
some sort of a treatment no no yeah yeah
I don't know it's weird yeah I remember
when when a couple of my events gonna
cancel and I was in shock then right and
now I'm more in shock that they're
trying to reschedule yeah yes it's
interesting how quickly you get used to
this new normal - right like now when I
watch movies people are hugging and
handshaking I'm like oh yeah yeah I had
a I was I'm gonna be in this commercial
I mean I don't know if they want me to
say what it is or whatever but but they
had to delay cuz there's like yeah it's
not the right time to put that one out
but that's we know we didn't shoot it
right like Jai right yeah
it doesn't matter didn't shoot it
yesterday that's so weird like the
perception like just just just the
appearance yes I mean I understand it
was got to be careful and whatever I'm
just I was just super excited to be in
it so I was like no but there's a
statistically at least San Diego seems
to have taken it much better than Los
Angeles did in terms of like fatalities
and one of the superintendent's was a
supervisor or superintendent said that
there's only six deaths that can be
directly attributed to nothing but
coronavirus then everything else had
people with underlying causes which is
pretty extraordinary
yeah I mean yeah so hard to know what to
believe - that's a problem right yeah
yeah that's the problem when like San
Diego is a really healthy place like
every time I'm down there like Pacific
Beach way like people are always running
and biking it's like yeah it's special
County doors II yeah I would imagine
just that alone would lend itself to
people having stronger immune systems I
would hope so but like I said it still
it still feels like a great divide even
there really yeah where people you know
when they
opened the beaches and then there was
only one beach in our area open and it
was like spring break just nuts yeah and
then you know people are frustrated with
each other what are you doing put
everyone at risk and it just it was a
mess nothing like all right but now it's
closed down for good and then everyone
just goes up to Newport or wherever they
can and then got more crowded there and
it's just it was it was a mess
well their own ideas are pretty open now
right isn't that the new thing you can
go surfing but you can't park on the
beach
um that's so stupid which is which is
very challenging but hey at least we're
surfing but that's so dumb why can't you
park there if you're like what's
happening to people when they park it's
like some of these rules are so
arbitrary yeah and like and you never
know what you know what is the rule now
changes day by day but it does feel like
there's definitely a slow opening
happening yeah so when we're talking
about San Diego being like very fit
place do you do any sort of strength and
conditioning or anything for
skateboarding is that something that
people do some people do it I never
found it to help my skating and I always
felt like skating kept me fit so I never
really did it I mean outside of swimming
and surfing which is more of her body
than skating obviously but um but I do
feel like that would have benefited me
later in life I just got stuck in my
mode and then just skating was you stay
there you're in your mode now you don't
do anything I don't do anything else I
do I do make an effort to like swim some
laps because my mom lived till her 90s
and she swore by swimming amazing yeah
yeah she would go you know through I
mean I remember all as a kid she would
definitely she had to get her twenty
laps in every day and and we we are are
where I live the residential area had a
community swimming pool that was like
Olympic sized so yeah we were talking
before about surfing and I was saying
that I think that surfing at least
partially would
kind of mimic some of the muscles that
you use in skateboarding and then you're
telling me about getting towed in by
Laird and rink his coffee Wow yes so
well my brother my older brother was a
surfer and he got me into skating
because he skated in the 70s when that
was the thing was they were trying to
emulate surfing with the skateboards and
so he actually gave me one of his old
boards that was my first skateboard and
then he would drive me to the skate park
once a week like come home from college
and take me to the park and then I just
got hooked like that was that was my
home away from home
from that point on and so I surf pretty
regularly I would say less now but but
it was hard not to with my brother's
influence and we were in Hawaii
my brother he actually used to be the
editor of Surfer magazine so he knows
all because he's journalists really good
writer teaches at Stanford now actually
and so we went to why we went to Maui
and he said hey Laird said he'd take us
out tow-in surfing if you want to go
we're gonna go tones were with Laird
Hamilton like that I don't think his
level of what is mellow is something
that is what we would consider and he's
and I go but you know we got to go like
it's once-in-a-lifetime right so they
took us out to Spreckels which is near
Jaws which is there a big spot this is
like early 2000s so toen serving was
just starting to come into play I'll
never forget Dave Kalama who's one of
the surfers one of his homies he was
trying out the first foil board there oh
wow and he had he was wearing ski boots
attached to the foil board that's how he
was riding it I was like these guys are
out of their minds and and so detached
like a ski boot if you fall I never saw
a detach he's God yeah so you have to
recover and and swim to the surface
while you're permanently student focused
on trying to survive myself to worry
about what he was doing
but yeah so rush Randall has another
windsurfer there he was towing me and
Laird is towing my brother and I'll
never forget them being outside and then
you know they're saying it's a small day
and they're like oh I think there might
be like it some 10 or 12 foot sets and I
know what 10 or 12 foot in Hawaiian
measurement means that was like kid just
don't tell me into one of those okay and
and then I'll never forget looking out
and and rush said here comes one like
where where cuz you're so far out right
he's like get ready okay and so then I
got ready and I'm getting towed and all
of a sudden this this thing this
mountain just swells up underneath me
and before I know it I'm just in the pit
of this move this way there was like
double overhead biggest way I've ever
ridden for sure and for me its backside
so when you're going backside you're
just sort of looking down the line
you're not looking back at the at the
barrel what does that mean by backside
so the wave is breaking this way and my
back went over my back is to the face of
the wave oh okay right and it back sides
a little more challenging just because
the turning and and the way you're
facing mmm so when you go in front side
you're facing the wave you can really
see down the line you can come back
easily so I'm going back side and I
remembered looking at looking at the
wall thinking like I've ridden 20 foot
skate ramps and I'm like that's that
looks like about a 20 foot skate ramp so
I was going and I was cruising and then
I did a little cutback so I started
going to back towards the barrel and I
looked at the barrel and it was like the
most frightening thing I've ever seen in
my life because it was you know it was
like a massive hollow wave that you see
in movies that you see lair just dancing
around in and I'm like I can't I'm not
getting near that thing
immediately just turned back and went
down alive even further just get ahead
of it and then I did find myself after a
few waves getting cocky and I tried to
pull into the barrel and it just
clobbered me in the head and then I you
know you wearing a life vest and then I
went down I'll never forget like I felt
myself going down one shelf and you know
trying to swim up to the top and then I
fell to go down another
shelf and I was like oh this is bad and
then finally made it up to the surface
and Russia's like three feet from me Wow
because he's just been chasing those
guys are they're the Masters experts and
yeah covering people to get clobbered
yeah [ __ ] and I was just like how long
were you down for I you know it wasn't
it wasn't like a crazy hold down but in
my inexperience and and not conditioned
body it felt like a long time and I and
I told rush I was like well that was so
scary has never been you know held down
enough much he's like yeah I've had my
worst hold downs out here thanks I was
telling you you know I get in the sauna
every day and I said something to Laird
he sent me a picture of his pulled up
here it's he's at two hundred and fifty
[ __ ] degrees in his sauna I mean I
don't even understand why he would do
that
but he's like I'm pissed that this thing
doesn't go any hotter yeah he lives on a
different plane he gets in there with
oven mitts at 250 degrees without here
it is look at this crazy [ __ ]
look at that
so does he wear oven mitts so his skin
won't melt off yeah cuz he rides his
[ __ ] airdyne bike so the metal of the
airdyne bike would literally cook him I
mean I cook a steak at 250 degrees in
the smoker this is crazy and it's 200
it's actually like probable it's it's
pinned at 250 cuz that's as hot as this
thermostat oh yeah right like it's
probably hotter than 250 he's out of his
[ __ ] nuts
um he's felonies always better is his
quote to me I just there's got to be a
point I did it once here I was trying to
after he came on the podcast I was
trying to copy him so I was doing it
like 210 and I did once at 220 I was
burning like the inside of my throat
from breathing in the air I was I
thought oh yeah King myself because I'm
there for like 20 minutes of like and
then that get out and it was as tired as
I've ever been in my life oh just
collapse on the mats after I got out of
the sauna I was like I gotta stop doing
this and I come in and do podcast I'm
like I was having a hard time talking I
was
like my throat was cooked it was
basically getting cooked yeah I never
did well with that stuff at we um we got
one actually we got one of the infrared
ones those are different though yeah he
doesn't like the infrared ones Laird
said that they gave him a real bad skin
condition and that like there's
something about is particularly the
temperatures putting him at yeah well I
got to start somewhere I'm not gonna
well I think the dry heat it's like
that's where the studies have been done
on them and I'm sure there's some
benefits to the infrared one but
according to him he's not into it yeah
well I don't like I said I don't really
do it anyway my wife my kids they like
going in there but I used to go in for a
little bit and like watch one episode of
something I'm like okay I'm done
have you done his crazy water workouts
no way no I would never survive that not
at this no I have a bunch of friends
that have gone up there and trained with
them and then they just text me
afterwards what the [ __ ] yeah because
he's just not no one no one can can go
easy no he's not eat there's no easy
with Larry there's only two speeds I was
talking about his ankle he came in here
and showed me his ankle he has an ankle
that broke that he never did anything to
he never bothered getting a cast he
never bothered getting it surgery and
it's it's like the root of a tree it's
this [ __ ] up thick ass knee of an
ankle it's so weird
and like wow that's next level he's just
a next level human yeah yeah absolutely
I mean I I respect him and admire him
but I don't want him to train me
well his workouts are so crazy like they
take a 75 pound dumbbell and they swim
with it like the whole gotta be piped on
Dumbo and then you're swimming across
the pool with one arm while holding the
seventy five-pound dumbbell while trying
to pop your head up and breathe in like
oh okay yeah whatever yeah so not not my
conditioning but I'd like that there's a
guy like that out there out for sure I
think it's important leading the charge
yeah just some [ __ ] maniac exactly it
was just so he's so psycho about
everything the guy sends you a 250
degrees sauna that he's mad
get any higher just it's so interesting
but I think like in terms of a guy like
that who's like a world-famous big wave
surfer guy you almost have to have that
kind of mentality and I would imagine
the same thing at least in some way has
to transfer over to skating and take
it's kind of everything right I think so
i think i think that there's a well
there's one there's an adventurous
spirit but also there's a sense of
self-confidence that you gain and that
you explore like you want to see how
much further you can take it yeah you
want to test the limits and identified
with that for sure that's always been my
drive just to come up with new tricks
like I knew the first time I ever did a
trick like a new trick and one that
hadn't been done before the buzz that I
got from it was what I've been so what
I've been chasing my whole life you know
the idea that I created something new
like just on my own with my own thoughts
and and creativity and that like I did
it my own way and you know skateboarding
was like that it was like this art form
to me where you there's this blank
canvas and it's just like go make it
your own
oh that's an interesting way to look at
it I never thought of it that way yeah I
mean it really is cool to look at so it
is an art form sure it's like you could
show me a picture of two people doing
the same trick silhouette it and I could
tell you who it is oh you know what I
mean because everyone has their own
style and they put their own flavor on
it and and that's what I love like I
love that it's it's subjective like that
you know people think of it like they
don't like skaters themselves especially
the more hardcore purists don't like to
be called a sport they're like we're not
a sport like well there's legitimate
competitions so yeah and there is
sporting element to it but I agree it is
more of an art form and a lifestyle
because how can you you're comparing
apples to oranges always that's real
similar in a lot of ways to martial arts
in that like if I saw silhouette of
certain people I'd say oh that's you
know that's John Jones or that's John
Parr like you could tell by the way
someone move
like right away yeah just because you're
gonna put your stamp on it yeah and
that's what I love about it because it's
so diverse yeah when you come up with a
move like what's your process you just
skate [ __ ] around have some fun and then
go just try this it's always different a
lot of times it's like how do we combine
how can I combine these two things that
I know I have dialed in like can I make
them work together sometimes it's a
happy accident like you go try something
your board spins the other way and it's
like well wait if I caught it there that
would have worked out mmm like yes sir I
literally created a new trick yesterday
yesterday yeah because we are doing this
when will this air tomorrow tomorrow
what we're doing up we're doing sort of
a we call it an NBD best trick event and
my ramp
NBD me has never been done and so my
idea was that and this is all this law
come out but my idea was that while
we're all stuck you know doing this
social distancing and whatnot let's do a
best trick event where everyone gets one
hour on my ramp all the best vert
skaters so you get one hour to do it you
get a check on video so it's literally
just one dude and or one one skater and
one filmer at the ramp at a time and I
was the guinea pig so yesterday morning
was like alright you're the first hour
go and and I had to come up with this
trick and I started trying one that I
had been working on and it just kept
slipping away like getting worse every
attempt and so I went I went and sort of
switched gears into a trick that I had
tried a couple months ago and was like
if you're ever gonna make this happen
this is it and finally one just clicked
and I made it and it was just like it
was it was the combination of two tricks
that I have pretty dialed but putting
them together added this element of just
so much to miss hmm like they all you
know everything had to come together at
the exact moment and land on my feet
on the coping in the right position and
and I knew if I got it once I'd make it
but like I'm never gonna do that trick
again that's how technical it is oh wow
where I just know that okay I got that
one done it got it on video I don't want
to go through that again
now how much I don't know [ __ ] about
skating so I like forgive me if there's
an ignorant question but how much
improvement has there been in the wheels
in the boards in the components and all
and all the different things like are
there things you can do now today they
just really weren't possible when you
first started skating only in the well
when I first started skating skateboards
were all over the place so they were
made of different materials they were
different with like all different shapes
they you know the urethane had just come
into play but I would say for the last
30 years it's pretty much the same
construction mmm
seven plywood maple skateboards trucks
have not changed wheels have changed in
size and hardness but it's still the
same urethane for the most part so there
hasn't been a lot of huge advancements
the bigger that the big changes are the
shapes of the boards now why have they
stuck with plywood
what about like carbon fiber you know
attic that is that's the big question
and and something that I would like to
pursue but we really need a sea change
in skateboarding with materials I
believe that yeah and we've we haven't
found anything that that responds the
same hmm
or you know it the other thing is
skaters as much as they are very
progressive and you know they like to be
do different things and and go it's
think outside the box and whatnot if you
try to sell them a deck that's you know
200 bucks that's how that's gonna be
hard hmm
even if you can convince them that it's
gonna last three times long four times
long so is it just a money thing or they
just haven't really felt like there's
some some people have done different
construction where they add a different
ply in and that has worked a little bit
but the I like I said there just hasn't
been that that one seed planted where
it's like all right this is it this
would imagine carbon fiber
I tried something along those lines and
it just like I said it didn't have that
reflux mmm does it have to have a
certain amount of weight to it to
because that that well that's the other
thing we're kind of stuck where this is
this is how skateboard should weigh
right and so if you bring in something
is way lighter maybe that's not the
answer
hmm but we don't know it just you know
it takes R&D for sure and you would have
to get someone really good to [ __ ] with
it too right yeah and to believe in it
and yeah get behind it yep when I was a
kid there was no 50 year old rock stars
you know yes rock stars as they were in
their 20s and 30s and then they just
kind of like we thought they faded away
like the Beach Boys everybody felt sad
about the Beach Boys Noize yeah but not
anymore you know now Mick Jagger is like
[ __ ] almost 80 years old and he's
rocking after heart surgery and [ __ ] and
the same is kind of true with skaters
right because when when we were kids
when you became famous you won't you
were like the first wave right or one of
the first waves and certainly the most
famous you are 52 and you're still
considering is that a weird thing that
you're it is weird it's it's well it's
fun right you can still do it and then
you're still you know I mean you're also
it's not like you're a dinosaur you're
accepted like you're you're a skater
it's like just you just happen to be 52
I mean yeah it well it went through the
years so when I first started skating
the the sort of unspoken rule was once
you're at an age of responsibility
you're 18 you got a good job hmm you
can't skate for a living no one can so
you know your skating career is over by
then and then as I turn 18 things
started to sort of ramp up with skating
forgive the pun but and things started
to kind of explode and I remember around
that time there was a photo and Thrasher
of this guy mark Lake was an older
skater at the time and he was picture
him doing one of those handplant like
upside down on a ramp and
was like mark lake 30 and still going
for it and I remember I was like in my
early 20s thinking that's crazy
he's 30 right and then as things
progress like we realized that that
we're all sort of if we're if we're able
to do this for a living and we can
really pursue it and we have support we
are were getting better into our 30s I
mean I you know when I did a 900 the
x-games I was 31 Wow and so then it was
just like well what is the limit I don't
know I'm I guess I'm sort of the guinea
pig now are leading the charge of what
how far you can take it and I've
definitely started I've refined my style
so I'm not doing big impact stuff I'm
not doing the the more you know the big
spins the big airs and stuff I've
learned to get more technical with my
skating and that has allowed me to stay
creative but maintain my health yeah
that's why I was asking about strength
and conditioning because if you're an
older athlete it's it's a mandatory
thing in almost every sport yeah it's
just I skate for a couple hours a day
I'd say four times a week and that's
pretty much my exercise but definitely I
could use some help with endurance these
days have you thought about doing
something like what would you do uh I
don't know I guess I would listen to the
experts I would tap you but you haven't
done anything yeah which is amazing I
haven't yeah but like I said it's just
because that's worked for me pretty much
my whole life yeah my only really
ailment is my neck what's wrong you know
just I've had so many whiplashes like
just you know we call them chicken necks
because you shoot out and and I've had
so many like different ways that
whenever I'm like if I'm sitting here
and someone were to call me over there
mm-hmm when I go to turn to look at them
they'll definitely say like what's wrong
with your neck Wow that happens to me
every day and I'm like what happened
what's wrong with my neck I don't know
40 years with a Blache have you got an
MRI yeah and I I do that's the only
thing that I get worked on so there's a
guy near where I
who does chiropractic but also does a
lot of body work and he just works on my
neck once a week just massages it yep
yeah Tracy a loose of a thing called an
iron neck yes
yeah I've ever used that I did try but
it was just awkward
yeah it's awkward but it's really good
yeah yeah it's a it's a must-have thing
for grapplers you should really try it
okay cuz I did it when we I did sort of
this racing training with Cadillac a
couple years ago and they're racers do
that mmm checking the check in their
mirrors yeah well it's great for
fighters to strong knack will keep your
head from snapping around no imagine the
same thing would happen with skaters yep
I've got one out here you should try it
afterward okay I done here it's I swear
by the thing it's it's the bet and it's
it's all so it doesn't [ __ ] with your
neck in a way that's unnatural in terms
of putting weight on your head and
flexing right your your discs it
actually keeps your neck stiff as well
as you know when you're when you're
turning it doesn't bend and unnatural
angles and it still strengthens it I'm a
giant fan of it okay well I'm open to
ideas now now because I would think that
like the whiplash thing that's that's
got to be real simple similar to what
happens with fighters you know oh yeah
for sure
yeah you know um it's weird though a lot
of like a lot of my peers they have more
knee problems and ankle problems and
I've just realized that all mines on my
neck you never had any problems well
I've had I had surgery I tore my
meniscus and both knees actually got it
cut out
tore my PCL but always came back from it
that's amazing yeah I mean I feel I feel
pretty lucky I was always very flexible
as a kid so I know that that was to my
advantage for sure oh for sure and like
I said when I went through the sort of
Street era of the early 90s I was
rolling my ankles left and right so I
never actually broke an ankle but but
they're loose they've got to play yeah
yeah I was really bummed out man because
I was seeing that they were trying to
keep these kids out of the skate park
yeah filled it with sand
see that show yeah what the [ __ ] man I
mean how much in vinet firt did it take
to do that and why that was a that was
very strange but how you get that stand
out there now ya know well you know what
if if if they say skate parks are open
the skater will do it their very own oh
yeah they're they're all very DIY
resourceful it's just like I did see
some fun in some helicopter footage on a
news feed where there was some guys that
actually dug a sort of a path so that
they could skate through the park so
they cleared out one area and they kept
trying like this guy was trying to get a
trick on video so they kept trying the
same trick and the helicopters just
shooed him I was like what world are we
living in so strange but imagine like
being in an office somewhere whatever
you know government office know like
well how do we stop these skateboarders
yeah I'm gonna have to truck in some
sand so they use our money these tax
money probably a lot of it too if you
think about how much sand that must have
got it just seemed like a very big
effort yeah [ __ ] giant effort already
is that is that they're trying to keep
skaters out of public areas and
schoolyards and stuff and give them a
place to go but now you're just forcing
them back to those days yeah it's not
like they're gonna stop going to
staircases and railing like a deal more
no that's so dumb but all of this it
sort of exposes some of the flaws and
governance
you know just it's very scattered well
skateboarding too it's it's almost like
some people would think of it as a
frivolous activity
sure like yeah glorious results of a
misspent youth if you know how to run a
skateboard
yeah it's funny the when I first started
I have a foundation for public skate
parks we've been gone 20 years actually
how does that were they well we we
basically give communities the resources
to get a part going like if someone in
the community has started a petition or
fundraising or just raising awareness
that they need a park we sort of give
them the roadmap to do that and funding
to do it oh that's amazing
um and you know designed help and things
like that so
it's been great we've helped to fund
over 900 skate parks now all 50 states
we've given away almost ten million
dollars that's incredible yeah I mean
it's definitely my proudest work but but
when when I started it there was a point
where I was we were trying to get
funding and trying to raise awareness
and you know I'm doing I'm doing visits
to children's cancer wards and stuff
like that and at some point I was like
I'm trying to build skate parks and I
remember um this conversation I had very
vividly actually with Lance Armstrong
when and this is when he was the face of
cancer research you know what I mean
like say what you will about his
competitive career but he did so much
for cancer awareness and research and
I'm visiting Children's Hospital with
Lance Armstrong and when Lance often
walks into a cancer ward back then like
the Seas part you know I mean it was
just like this it was like oh he's here
and I remember having lunch with him
didn't with that day and I was like it's
so weird to be with you you're you're
doing so much for cancer and cancer
victims and I'm just trying to build
playgrounds
yeah like concrete waves and he said he
said look the the the number one cause
of cancer or number you know number two
cause of cancer in the u.s. is obesity
and by building those skate parks you
are preventing cancer you're preventing
obesity Wow and that was heavy for me
that is heavy and and it really gave me
a lot of inspiration you know and a lot
more motivation why are you creating a
potential place for joy right and and
ferb you know for people to like-minded
people to hang out like to develop a
community I mean when I was a kid like I
felt like an outcast I felt like like I
didn't belong in in sports I didn't
belong in my school and when I went to
the skate park and there was this band
of misfits listening to punk music and
look you know weird hairdos from all
walks of life I was like this is it this
is my crew and I want the same sense of
community for you know we're not
try to build training grounds for
Olympians we're just trying to build a
place for them to feel like they belong
and feel like their community actually
cares about them yeah and it is a loved
pursuit I mean it even though it's had
these weird views like our peoples had
have had weird views about it if you
think about how many people love it and
how it requires this sort of a place
like what you're creating right to
really do it right in nowadays it's way
different now that the the sort of
perspective on skating or the attitude
towards skating is that parents are
doing with their kids like you know and
little girls are encouraged to try it
and that just wasn't the case when I was
a kid like I think it's because of you
in a lot of ways oh well thank you I
mean I've I was always happy to at least
advocate for skating and try to explain
to people like this has a real positive
impact on kids your look your you're too
focused on the hairdos and the music and
stuff you got to really look at what it
provides someone's mentality yeah but
that's always been the case with things
that kids do that their parents didn't
do sure like how many parents told their
kids to stop playing video games and now
kids are literally making millions of
dollars playing video games and parents
have to kind of make this adjustment
like ok yeah ok so I think the
generation of parents now grew up at a
time when skating was starting to be
cool yeah okay so either they're
encouraging of their kids skating or
they're actually skating with them
that's awesome that's gotta make you
feel good it's very cool
yeah impact on the thing that you love
yeah I mean the coolest part is for me
is that I still get to participate and I
get to bear witness to all this like you
know it's the oldest skater is there a
really old dude out there shredded sure
I mean the names like even that some of
the z-boy guys like Tony Alva still
skates I just saw up [ __ ] grinding a
pool I he's 60 something holy [ __ ] but
when you fall at 60 something yeah
that's rugged yeah well like he's really
I'm like I said I've kind of
narrowed down my discipline to the ramp
because I know how to fall on a ramp
right where the pads and that's what's
kept me going
but even that that's why I'm encouraging
strength and conditioning like when I
see people in their fifties that are
doing things I'm like okay but do you
lift weights cuz you should you know
really like just kind of [ __ ] trainer
man just keep your bone density that's
that's what's really a real problem when
people get older their [ __ ] breaks so
easy right things that normally you just
bounce off of and be fine and then all
sudden you like came this time clicking
in my arm oh my gosh [ __ ] I gotta go to
a hospital and then you know a normal
fall causes you to have a cast yeah I
learned that well I broke my pelvis oh I
was almost 40 I was doing a loop ramp
which is something that I had done many
times before that and the loop that we
were skating was kind of weathered and
kind of slow and I tried to adjust for
that and I just overshot it like I'd
shot out at the top and it just fell
straight to the bottom that's kind of
affect you Jamie broke his butt bone out
here with a hoverboard and he was [ __ ]
up you were [ __ ] up for lucky here
right yeah it came came and went I
thought I got fixed couldn't get fixed
no one I went to knew what was going on
it took he had a self identify what the
injury was and then who was it that had
a similar injury Zach bitter came and
said he had assassin got MRIs the doctor
told him he was okay and then they
really looked at it was like hey by the
way you have a small fracture and like
yeah we're and it just like your whole
body freezes up yeah walk for like 25
yards had to stop and sit yeah that
loosen I had the same thing and you know
those hoverboard things again yeah my
kids have them out here and they go
bananas out here in the warehouse and
yeah Jamie was [ __ ] around on it
while not totally paying attention I was
trying to practice and see if I could
film and stuff and my kid you know yeah
and we didn't really figure out what
what it was until Zach bitter explained
it then we thought about the I mean you
you're a 200-pound man or whatever you
weigh somewhere around there and fall
like on
for sure yeah on your [ __ ] like
that's that's a lot of weight like but
first do you know who Zach bidder is I
don't he's the world record holder for a
100-mile race he ran a hundred miles in
11 hours in like 40 minutes he's a
savage I mean just bananas and and then
he kept running afterwards you can grant
200 miles the long or the fastest around
100 miles on the treadmill cuz he was
doing it wise and Quarantine I think oh
my god Wow and he eats mostly meat
really yeah his diet is almost all
ribeye steaks and Wow
he he supplements it with like some
glucose supplements and things like that
while he's while he's doing that he did
it again
Zach bitter shatters hundred mild
treadmill world record oh my god he
averages 7-minute mile seven-minute 18
mile for a [ __ ] a hundred miles
that's so insane that's a anis an animal
how old is he um he's in his 30s right
Jamie yeah I just like he was still he
was still running while he had the
problem - oh yeah and it crazy here so
when I when I went through that the the
thing that I had to adjust mostly was
that I didn't realize I was um favoring
my back foot when I would skate because
the the fracture of my pelvis was on my
front leg front leg side and I ended up
injuring I actually got a ko'd once
because I was leaning back more than I
should have been and I thought I was
balanced and then found myself just on
my back like hey oh oh [ __ ] and then
another time I was putting so much
weight like because when you skate you
put one foot on the tail of the board
and I was trying to get speed for
something going on the big ramp and I
had so much force on my tail that I
broke it off like going through the flat
bottom of the ramp my tail just was left
behind me with my foot doing the splits
that's so crazy but and I realized that
that's when I realized that I needed to
readjust my weight distribution
because of my pelvis and try to figure
out how to how to skate properly again
Wow no how do you recover from that did
you have to go through the
rehabilitation did you I am basically
laid around sat around for almost two
months and then slowly started to walk
and then was skating about a like six
weeks after not walking and so you
didn't do any rehab um I did some stuff
in the pool I did have I did have a
trainer that was helping me a guy that I
knew that used to work on skate stuff so
he did help me for a few weeks and then
I started skating it was actually I was
I was working towards a goal we had a
big exhibition in Orlando that was
already booked and I was like alright
that's that's the time we thought was
that I want to say it was it was about
12 weeks from when I got hurt wow that's
a lot of time yeah to recover from a
bone break yeah I mean I you know I
didn't wasn't my best performance not my
best work but I got through it and then
really had to figure out how to rebuild
my confidence that's the thing I lost
the most mm-hmm because I started to
question everything now I can only
imagine so
mostly just laid around let it heal up
and then you had to do something to
build your muscle mass I was doing I was
doing a lot of stuff in the pool with
resistance oh my leg and stuff like that
that was that was pretty much it it was
just more I just felt stiff hmm and like
he said like when you have an injury
like that you can't
Koff like you know what I mean you can't
like sneezing if you feel a sneeze
coming on it's it's traumatic right
because everything hurts yeah it's about
the shot yeah and then like just going
to the bathroom is a trauma oh god right
- sitting right on the bowl I'm like
Christ oh damn dude wow that's amazing
though that you you got through that
with pool work but you could do some
great [ __ ] in the pool George st. Pierre
is like one of the best UFC fighters of
all time does the majority of his
workouts in the pool now he has these
things that he wears on his hands these
resistance things and he does like all
these
crazy workouts in the pool and doesn't
mind his legs and and and he does like
these jumps inside the pool and he does
it all just preserve his joints while
still you know building up muscle hmm
but it's so he's mostly focused on the
pool yes no seeming to find them they're
pretty cool too George st. Pierre pool
workouts yeah he has I mean he's he's a
fascinating guy really intelligent guy
and he's gone through a bunch of
different kinds of strength and
conditioning routines and and attitudes
about it over his career and one point
in time he really embraced gymnastics
and he got really into gymnastics but
now most of what he does he goes to the
pool and see these things he's wow yeah
I'm Scott like these like barbell
looking things and a bunch of different
different apparatus that he uses and the
you see these things he puts on his legs
and he develops his kicking power and
his jumping power and oh yeah that's my
alley right there it's really
interesting because you're really not
concerned about getting injured this way
but he gets this ferocious muscle
workout and he doesn't have to worry
about tearing things or you know hurting
himself because of weight yeah yeah I'm
gonna leave here with a whole new
attitude
yeah well it's C training working out
for sure thing to try especially for
someone who is fighting that was though
that was one of the things that when I
told my kids I was coming here do like
he's gonna talk to you about working out
you know I was like I'm sure and they go
but you don't work out a guy no [ __ ]
kids man they never let you take a break
they ride you if they find this one
thing oh yeah of course yeah what about
your diet are you healthy
do you eat healthier III I think so yeah
III what's that that's a well let's put
this way III I don't need to access like
I used to
mmm I think that's really what I've
learned getting older is just like don't
go crazy with everything you know
drinking eating like just eat too till
you're not overly full just eat enough
and and watch what I eat
for sure when I was a kid it was just
all it was all junk food everything it
was sugar cereals McDonald's
jack-in-the-box I mean our big going out
night with my dad was Bob's Big Boy
that was like we're living Laura Bank no
in San Diego okay yeah that was it I
mean without like I don't I never went
to nice places the the extent of his
nice place was like hey this guy's this
place does prime rib for five bucks okay
so I didn't like I didn't really grow up
with health health conscious diet and
then as I got older I discovered well
mostly just so much great food and then
realizing that you know I gotta get more
greens and and really watch it and so
I've managed to be able to do that I'd
say over the last 20 years
do you take supplements at all I do yeah
what do you take yeah I take I have a
whole bevy of stuff that this
nutritionist gave me I wish I could name
them all but I just know which bottles
they are but it's good and makes you
feel better definitely I can tell when
I'm when I've missed a day or two on
them I mean just in terms of how I feel
well people are so much more conscious
of that now I mean it's it's something
that pretty much in every athletic
pursuit anything where people are doing
things things physically so much more
calm really conscious of supplements and
diet and but I but I do have to admit
that I do love like barbecue of course
you know my wife's not much of a fan
really yeah
what's wrong with her she's she eats
much more healthy night she's more
Mediterranean okay in terms of her diet
have you ever gone to doctor hog laoag
Lee's in van nuys no there's a joint in
van nuys it's been around [ __ ]
forever you go in there it's like wood
paneled walls they've done zero for the
day car and no one gives a [ __ ] there's
always a line it's specta mom when its
open Kenny right now but it's some of
the best barbecue I've ever had anywhere
and it's in Van Nuys and there's semis
sketchy neighborhood Oh perfect yeah
yeah it's it's phenomenal
there's place in San Diego that I've
been going called Abbey's
that I think is pretty
my daughter loves barbecue too so that's
our big launch outing San Diego's got
some great food man
I've been going to San Diego forever I
started going to the La Jolla Comedy
Store yeah of course
way back in the 90s yeah it's a great
spot man and I might have actually seen
you there ah that's crazy
san Diego's never gotten too big you
know right it's yeah I try to tell
people it's one of the last small beach
towns but it's a city well buddy you
don't think if you fan out its what
should you go north yeah it's more like
no one can really build on the coastline
anymore so the the homes that are there
there and it's not gonna get any more
crowded mmm okay that makes sense
yeah well that's smart because they've
they've preserved a really nice spot yes
it's like the right size so you get
traffic there but it's a I'd stop
complaining it's not [ __ ] you know come
up here this is ridiculous this place is
even now with the quarantine it's still
you get on the road like what I thought
everybody's supposed to be home right
stay safe indoors it's [ __ ] five
o'clock traffic like real truck I was
telling you guys actually I was I was on
a I was on a zoom called just on audio
on the way up here and I was passing LAX
on 405 and usually it's just dead stop
right and finally I was just like oh man
oh so I turn the camera on and faced it
out but you guys got to see this
I'm Drive look at this there's the 105
there's lax I'm still moving yeah it
whenever I've done gigs in San Diego and
I have like an 8 o'clock show I'll leave
here at 11:00 in the morning I'm like
there's no way oh yeah yeah I'm not
taking any chances yeah it could easily
take five hours yeah
you know we sound like that SNL skit the
Californians have you ever thought about
living in New where else um not really
my wife and I sometimes sort of muse
about we'd love to live in New York once
all of our kids are out but probably for
a brief time it's gonna be real weird
now
yeah apparently was a mass exodus out of
there right now
I was there right before everything
turned upside down Wow and it was
already feeling it's shaky I don't know
they look we went out we went out to
dinner we saw our friends band form this
little Club and there was a sense of
unease what year what month was that was
in early March oh yeah so it was just
starting to get there or no no no it was
in February sorry oh yeah but it was
like late it was just there was
something in the air we knew something
was gonna change the buddy mind caught
it there in New York yeah my god my
tooth skater my age and he went through
hell no yeah it seems like the New York
strain what they got in the East Coast
they were saying is coming from Europe
it's a stronger strain than the strain
that they got here in California it's
coming from China yeah my my oldest son
and I were extremely sick in February
both like as six we've ever been we were
convinced that we had gone through it
once everything like and so I managed to
I managed to get a test I had to pay
through the nose it wasn't you know the
tests are not available but yeah I
lucked into one and we both didn't have
it interesting yeah we've been testing
pretty much everybody I didn't test you
but we've been testing everybody that
comes here we just have a concierge
service comes here concierge m.d. LA or
oh wow yeah it's nice how do i lock in
luck out I don't know just didn't test
you didn't ask I [ __ ] up my mistake
okay well I was negative as a month ago
I was have a month ago that's good okay
cool I was I've been tested I got tested
last weekend I took the swab because I
flew to Florida for the UFC event so I
had to swab before that I had the
antibody test and then I got it again
when it came back all negative we did
have one fighter test positive though
he's asymptomatic and his two cornermen
were asymptomatic too which is one of
the weirdest things about this and he
discovered it here they found out in oh
he's from Florida but they found out
when he arrived that he knew that
someone at his family had had it and so
he was cautious and more gloves and
masks in the whole deal and didn't make
contact with anybody other than the
people that he was with ever you know
the entire time and then they found out
before the fight that he was positive
Wow yeah but ever all the other fighters
they did 1,100 tests and only three
people were positive and they kind of
knew that they had a potential for being
positive even though they were
exhibiting no symptoms it's just wild
right now it's weird and we called the
event that was what was really wild
calling the event with no audience at
all I saw it
strange man yeah just [ __ ] strange
I'm just I can tell you watching it at
home with my kids they had the same
excitement level oh me too
I mean it was great the fights were
amazing the judge of judging was [ __ ]
terrible there's some really bad
decisions but the fights were incredible
was just it was so it was just great
just to do something to be I was curious
about that though do you think the
fighters had a different sense of energy
or motivation because they didn't have a
crowd I don't know what motivations any
different it might be a little bit less
stressful slightly obviously it's a
[ __ ] cage fright it's gonna be
stressful but maybe a little less
stressful because you don't get the roar
of the crowd it's not the energy in the
place maybe you could focus a little bit
better but you know there in the UFC so
they're fighting the best fighters in
the world so that's no matter what
certain mindset you're getting into you
regard yeah but it was just interesting
because they could clearly hear their
corner so when their corners were
yelling out instruction and when the
opposition corner was yelling it alright
yeah they could he'll hear all that and
we could hear that too like crystal
clear not a sound in the room and you
could hear the breathing and the the the
impact of the shots way better it was a
lot that's a new element it was a lot
different it's really strange you know
wow are they gonna have skating
competitions with no audience as well
that remains to be seen I assume that's
probably where it's gonna go
I'm not part of the whole Olympic
qualifying thing going on so I don't
know what they're going to do or how
they're gonna continue to qualify people
going into next year yeah we had an
event
and that was supposed to happen in June
in Salt Lake City
big verts cake on test and it has been
pushed to August and I don't know if we
can do it with the audience or not
well Utah's opening up I mean they're
doing comedy shows there now restaurants
are opening up now they're they're
opening up some things so cautiously
opening up some things yeah I'm not
altima ting I'm not the one that will
decide if it happens or not but I hope
that we can get it done with the
necessary guidelines and whatnot because
I do feel like um our our type of
skating which is the vert skating is
sort of a lost art that's not going to
be in the Olympics by the way so the
what is this the first year that skating
is gonna be yes yep yeah well next year
but yes sir is it twenty twenty-one
twenty twenty-one yeah interesting
so skateboarding the disciplines are
Street which is sort of the handrails
and stare as ledges of stuff like that
you see and then what they call Park and
park is sort of a mishmash of pool
skating but also some other skatepark
elements like banks and and curves and
things like that so it's more because
that type of skating is more accessible
especially internationally then what we
call vert skating but it's kind of a to
me it's a disservice to skating because
vert skating like you said it's the
thing you can understand if you're not a
skater people are flying around they're
doing gymnastics they're doing
somersaults there you know and and that
type of stuff you see a very muted
version of that in Park skating hmm and
why do they fix choose those events I
think that's it because the
accessibility and I have to I have to
respect that that's just nice thread
since you know there's a there's like a
strong skate not I mean there is a skate
scene in places like Ethiopia and
Ethiopia has parks they don't have vert
ramps obviously so I understand on that
level you're gonna have a much more
well-rounded competitive field that's
cool that Ethiopia is embraced Gate
boarding I see that yeah
you've been there yeah see here it is
Jamie's already got it the best in the
business young Jamie look at this wow
that's [ __ ] cool
wow that's not what I picture when I
think of Ethiopia right I mean that
looks like that could be Atlanta that
could be anywhere yeah absolutely I mean
that kind of thing is happening all over
the world mmm
there's there's a I don't know if you've
heard of SCADA Stan but SCADA stan is a
skate for lack of a better word camp
facility and educational facility in
Afghanistan in Kabul and they teach
girls they teach girls they give them
education and they learn how to skate
whoa in fact there was a documentary on
them the won an Academy Award at the
last Oscars really yeah do you get
anything on that that was that was my in
for what's called learning to skate
that's skater Stan it's called learning
to skate in a war zone if you're a girl
that's the name of the documentary
that's got to be very dangerous for them
though right because the fundamentalists
don't want them doing well so that's the
thing is is that they they see it the
culture sees skateboards as a toy not a
sport and allows girls to do it oh wow
so they don't they don't see it as this
co-ed sport at all and so it's really
interesting that the ratio of boys to
girls are equal skating in Afghanistan
and same goes for they have another
program in Cambodia and they have one in
South Africa I've been to all of them
are not a couple but look at that I'm
sure that is so wild the mountains of
Afghanistan the background oh yeah girls
catching there are there programs in say
they're there they're one of the best
wow that's wild
that's crazy as skating is that's crazy
that during your lifetime skating has
just blossomed and gone from this sort
of misfit thing to something that's in
the Olympics in an Ethiopia Afghanistan
all over the world that's why it is wild
yeah it's really every day is like a new
surprise
now when they do it in the Olympics what
is the scoring criteria like how do they
how do they judge
um I well I don't think they're gonna
reinvent the wheel in terms of how they
judge I think that they have to be very
concise with their criteria now in terms
of writing it down because before it was
just sort of loose and that guy you know
that skater ripped and went higher and
looked cooler and we gave him first and
now it's got to be much more but but
it's more it's more about technical
aspects like how the difficulty factor
how you flow like how you link tricks
together how much speed you have how
high you go I mean all those factors but
at the end of the day when you go to the
skate contests you can tell the the top
skaters it's it's just obvious that they
they were ripping they used the course
better you know they went higher they
spun more they flip their board hard in
in more difficult ways and they're the
winners and now do you have former pros
or current pros the judges I'm not
really sure who how they're picking
judges I'm not like I said yeah a
standard competition a lot of them racks
pros yeah and so there's pretty like
universal acceptance of like what what's
good and what's bad yeah it's always up
for debate
yeah who should have won that event or
this or how to manage their at the level
that these guys around it's probably
quite a few guys that are comparable
right sure yeah so it's basically how
good your run was how good your run was
yeah and and who had a better day
similar to surfing in that regard
absolutely yeah yeah yep so that's
what's interesting for someone like me
watching like I'm not exactly sure what
I'm seeing I know what looks cool but I
don't know what what what one you know
sure yeah and I and I think that well I
I'm hoping that that will be my job to
explain to the audience I I was supposed
to be there in Tokyo
doing some commentary not not ville
play-by-play but more sort of you know
coming in and out of there and doing
whatever shows they need me to do but
so I would like to loan the Olympics for
a year or a year yeah mm-hmm hmm so you
would like to I would like to be there
to try to to try to bridge that gap
right of the the non skating viewer who
is interested and explained to them why
you know why this this nuance is gonna
score way higher than this other but
even though they look the same to you
yeah and I've done it I've done like
they had the van's Park series all last
year where we went to all over the world
went to China Brazil Canada France and
they built these parks that they left
there but I was doing all the the
commentary for the events and that was
kind of where that's where my strengths
are is is being able to explain those
things to non skaters well that's gotta
be fun for you too because it's an
opportunity to sort of you know
proselytize let everybody know like like
show them how cool this is yeah yeah
words to your passion this thing and I
mean that's got a really spark up the
interests of new skaters I think that's
the silver lining with the Olympics I
mean there there is a lot of controversy
in the hardcore skate scene where it's
just like we're not we don't blowing
lumic we've always done this to be anti
that type of thing anyway yeah and and
then it's just like well you guys all of
those things you love ice skating will
still exist right you can still go hop
fences and ski the hint we're like
that's not taken away from you if
anything it's going to bring it to a
bigger audience that that is going to be
interested yeah and I believe a more
international audience I think that's
the really cool part about it that's a
thing though man when people when things
start going mainstream people always
panic right but that's the other thing
is this like if you think that the
competition element is what is somehow
sanitizing skating whe that I grew up
skating competitions I literally enter
my first contest at age 10 that is the
only way you got recognized when I was a
kid like the way this is not something
new to skateboarding it's just that now
there are different opportunities in
skating and there is a way to make a
living even if you don't compete
and so because that exists people are
just like Olympics are a comment you
know if that's a sport competition like
yeah but we already have Street League
we already have the do too or we already
have X Games those things all exist so
we're gonna have this other big event
once every four years and people always
want to [ __ ] on something that's
different than what they're doing though
oh sure it seems like I mean had I've
lived with so much ridicule my whole
life that I just think it's like yeah
sure whatever you say well for you I
mean you've crossed over to the other
side that's what's interesting I mean
you don't even need a thick skin anymore
yeah I mean there's obviously still
haters like you're a sellout and whatnot
but it's like do you read those comments
I just don't wither or anything dear III
like I if someone's making enough noise
I'll see it and you know everyone some
well I like to see what the what the
general vibe is on something but when I
grew up like I think my journey allowed
me to really be prepared for that
because when I was a kid I was doing
this outcast activity right so I was
already not cool in school and then I
started skating and I was like a scrawny
little kid with a really sort of what
they call robotic style because I was
focusing on tricks so I was getting made
fun of in the skate world so I was like
an outcast in this outcast activity and
it was really isolating and at some
point I was like I love this too much to
listen to these people and not do it
look explain to me what you were getting
[ __ ] on for like you had a robotic style
so basically what in when I first
started getting into skating especially
pool skating to be a pool skater you had
to be super cool look like you're
surfing it was all about your style
right and it was all about like how you
flow and if you're doing aerials it's
got to look cool and and I was super
scrawny super short kid and so all I
really knew how to do was to maneuver my
board and so I was doing these tricks
where I'd like spin my board under my
feet and do these weird sort of hand
plants and aerial tricks and things
where it just wasn't that wasn't the
normal and it wasn't really considered
the
way to skate and so they just they were
like there's they call me a circus
circus skater you're like oh there's
Tony with the circus tricks oh wow
and then it's someone I just like I
loved what I was doing and I didn't
really listen it and then I got I got
more confident and I got stronger and
then I started doing this stuff like way
up high in the air and then it was sort
of undeniable that it was like oh well
that is something so was there pressure
for you to change your style and sort of
blend it I just didn't have I didn't
have the the bulk to be able to do it
anyway so I didn't ball yeah like I just
didn't have that weight behind me and so
what I did was when back then in order
to do aerials out of pool as you had to
like reach down grab your board and sort
of muscle it into the air and above the
coping and I learned how to launch into
the air without grabbing my board and
then grabbing it at the peak and that
allowed me to get the height when I was
still really scrawny and weak and they
said that technique was cheating like
they literally wrote that and Thrasher
Magazine it's like well Tony Hawk cheats
because he always into his air isn't
that way he can just grab it wherever
and I was just like yes that's exactly
it that's what I'm trying to do that's
so it so they would judge you on like
that's so crazy here's this invented
thing right right art form and then
you're doing it your way and they're
saying you're cheating yeah yeah I don't
it just it was just like this old guard
in skating and they just didn't like to
see anything new or or sort of fringe
and then I started doing that and then
and then a lot of my peers who were my
age they all figured that same technique
out and then we just kind of took over
you know that became the way to skate
and but but then through the years like
in those days you know skating was still
very much a novelty and then in the 90s
like X Games came into play and then all
of a sudden my name was was being well
it was well known not mainstream but but
getting there and then our video game
came out and then it was just like oh
you're just a cell
and it was like because of the video
game because the video game the
endorsements that followed from that you
know I was doing stuff for Jeep from
McDonald's for Doritos and they were
just like oh you just said I was like
when I turn pro at age 14 if McDonald's
had asked me to be in a commercial I
would have jumped on it are you kidding
me
like I was eating McDonald's my whole
life I still do so it was more like they
thought someone I changed my values and
was just like I haven't changed my value
system it's just that I'm getting these
opportunities finally and I've been
doing this for most of my life for the
most part it's you're getting
opportunities that they're not so the
best way to dismiss that or diminish it
is to say that you're a sellout cuz
you're on a video game that's so
short-sighted sure but but you know but
but so what I'm saying is that just sort
of that sort of steeled my resolve where
so once the social media came into play
and people are talking [ __ ] online I was
like you're not getting to me this you
know this through this media right
people used to say this to my face used
to write about this just write about me
in magazines like you're hiding behind
your Twitter username I don't care when
you first saw someone say that you were
cheating by using that technique how bad
that must have sucked up yeah and it was
from it was from a skater that I really
respected to look he was quoted in the
magazine and that was it was crushing
wow that's such a bitch-ass approach you
know cheating that's so weird to me
because I never would have I guess it
makes sense because there's always
factions in any discipline or any art
form or anything with some people
respect some things and other people
[ __ ] on it and but the idea that you
doing it your way would somehow or
another be cheating to me it seems so
strange that doesn't make any sense like
I said it was it was just weird because
skating was there's a small community at
the time and it was like why are you
like why are we fighting in our little
tiny world it's always gonna be that way
yeah that's just humans yeah especially
when you're doing something different
especially if you're getting attention
doing something different they're gonna
find some way to diminish you yeah it
was just it was it was harder for me
because all I wanted to be was
accepted as a skater mm-hmm you know I
kind of given up on my peers on my
schoolmates I knew I wasn't gonna fit in
there and so I was like I found this
thing and they're just like you guys
don't like I mean either way do it rough
but look you hung in there and came out
on the other end yeah and I don't I
don't harbor any elbow you know me a lot
of people are like oh you should go back
to school like you go to your reunion
and I was like I don't it's not some
revenge for me I loved I'm just so
thankful that I still get to do this for
a living like this is seriously living
the dream like I get to do this for a
living I get to come on your show
because I'm a skateboarder like the
stuff that I've gotten to do over my
life is beyond any dream I could have
ever written or imagined and it's all
because I just kept skating that is the
American dream to me or sure why dream
the human dream absolutely to be able to
do what you want for a living and to
continue doing it yep and if support
your family and to you know it's crazy
the kind of stuff that yeah that we've
gotten to do especially as a family like
it's kind of trips we've taken and
people we've met for skating that's
amazing do you still talk to that guy
who's [ __ ] on you back then do you know
who that guy I didn't do I think he fell
on some hard times
Wow that's how it usually goes with
haters but it's it's interesting though
that there's been these waves of change
inside of it during your lifetime you
know that it's such an evolving sort of
growing thing that from the time you
were a kid to now it's almost just a
totally different thing but yet still
skating yeah I mean at its core the
feeling I get when I'm on a skateboard
is the same like when I just go out just
practicing on my ramp or in our backyard
or whatever I can just feel that that
happiness that sort of peace and can
like it's the one thing in my life and
I'm fully in control of and I just like
that's my escape that's so cool that you
still enjoy it like that yeah I never
imagined that I never imagined skating
into my 30s
do you have friends that are your age it
also yes Phil scary I have a couple
friends that a couple years older than
me and they're sort of my you know
they're my gauge so do you have like a
crazy setup in your back yard I have a
small concrete setup
that's not huge but but you know it's
fun and then I have a proper size big
vert ramp in my office and I mean in the
last two months those even places I'm at
is it an indoor thing the vert ramp door
yeah how high is it it is for uh 13 and
a half 14 feet Wow so you just go there
and [ __ ] around and have fun and yeah
this yeah we've done a couple of live
streams from there just to provide
entertainment for people oh that's cool
yeah and we did one with the DJ z-trip
he was doing them like mixing up on the
deck and we were doing tricks up on his
up on his table that was pretty cool and
then we are working on this best trick
NBD thing I'm actually got some some
money from a sponsor so you know just
trying to make content make
entertainment as best we can what are
the content do you make online do you do
a podcast for anything or video I used
to I used to be on Sirius XM I'm
actually that was the first time I
reached out to you because I had a
serious XM show for 10 years and I
stopped doing it just because it was I
kind of went as far as I could with
getting guests and and I just wasn't
really moving up the ladder and it was
really hard to maintain that schedule
was you know it was it was only once a
week but for me it was like I got a book
studio time in LA I Drive up here beg so
I mean I didn't have like I didn't have
anyone running the show so it was just
more like hey does anyone know Seth
Rogen okay but I had a good run I mean I
definitely liked my last two guests were
Pharrell and Seth Rogen oh that's why I
felt like all right that's sports guy
no Pharrell oh the Williams yeah oh wow
yeah oh wow that's that's a big get was
yeah so I felt like if if I'm not I
can't really go further with this idea
and let's just end it here so it was fun
though do you do anything with it now do
you do anything like that now um no not
really I mean I
I'm happy to but it's so easy to do some
sort of a podcast now it is yeah I just
don't I guess I just don't want to be
that guy that's like hey man do my
podcast yeah
cuz that's how I felt when I like sent
you the first message on Twitter I was
like hey you wanna call my Sirius XM
show and that was right when your show
started blowing up and I saw you I was
like oh he doesn't talk from my show I
did I mean I'm looking I'm happy you
came to do this I think what you've done
in your life is it's like a great road
map for young kids that are sitting out
there trying to figure out if they can
make a living doing something they love
you know that's that's the road map I'm
all for sure I try to tell people - you
don't have to you don't have to be the
best in your field - to enjoy to make a
living at it like you can maybe find
some angle on it that maybe isn't even
the thing but you get it gets you in the
door and you get to be part of the
community or the industry and you can
live like that whether it's doing video
or art or you know behind the scenes
you're still part of that scene and it's
still super cool and and I feel like
that's what's lost on kids they just
want to be the best they want all the
stardom and it's just like now think of
something that is that you would enjoy
and make that your job because that's
for me that's what success is that's
such an American mindset the mindset of
I need to be the best I need to be
number one right yeah yeah and that
that's just the thing that sucks about
that mindset is that if you do reach any
sense of that a lot of times that's when
it all falls apart how so I feel like a
lot of people get a taste of it and
they're no longer motivated do you know
anybody okay I think in a lot of cases
I've seen in skateboarding especially
where they just want to be they want to
get in the magazine they want to be or
win the contest and then they finally do
and they're not motivated to keep it
going that's interesting or to progress
their own skating hmm so instead of just
enjoying it they they in there and the
competition is the end meet the end goal
means to an end and then and then
there's no more inspiration that's a fun
thing that's a funny thing rather for a
lot of people in in any art form or any
sport they you know once they reach a
pinnacle it's very difficult to keep
momentum up that's what happens we're a
lot of Fighters oh yeah they've reached
the top and then they they don't have
the same enthusiasm they had when they
were younger and then of course the
trappings of Fame the cow and that's yet
another distraction another you know and
some people that's what they revel in
yeah and you can lose sight of I mean I
think that's what I was lucky that I was
young enough and had success and I saw
some of my peers kind of fall into that
and I saw how it affected their skating
and that was my signal mmm like if you
follow that road your sketti is gonna
suffer and my focus was always getting
better at skating that's interesting
that happens with comedy a lot of times
guys get really famous and then their
specials they start to fall right they
like when they're on the come-up their
specials are edgy and they're really
into it they're poor they're they're all
into it and then they become famous and
like that was the thing with Kinison
like he's partying with rock stars yeah
hanging out I saw him in it during those
days did you really on San Diego you
could tell that he could just come out
and scream and everyone's like yeah oh
so this must have been like 86 87 yeah
he he did a thing where he called people
from the audience to come up and then
call their ex-girlfriend their ex girl
yeah I saw him do that at in Mansfield
Massachusetts yeah but in his day man he
was a genius oh he was the best for a
couple years is probably the best ever
but then the the trappings of Fame
yeah just God's when we stop right his
brother wrote about it is there's a book
called brother Sam his brother Bill
wrote this whole book about this sort of
meteoric rise and one of the things that
he said was that you know once it became
famous he was like stealing coke and
partying all night and it really wasn't
writing anymore and wasn't out there
trying to put the other sets and he
definitely wasn't keeping his seat
that he was doing it no no he was
partying well listen man appreciate you
coming in here was really cool to meet
you I was it was my pleasure thank you
it's an honor to be here I think your
story's [ __ ] amazing it's really cool
I love hearing stories like that where
someone finds something they love and
they just just follow their dream and
they become famous and successful at it
it's just it's so cool
yeah I'm still still chasing that carrot
chased that carrot baby
thank you thanks brother appreciate you
man Tony Hawk ladies and gentlemen
good bye thank you
[Music]
[Music]